should we see our friends as a commodity
that we should invest in or not no we
shouldn't and should we support friends
even if they're going through a bad time
yes we absolutely should but if this
person their personality just happens to
be a and as a byproduct of you being
around them you feel like it as well
that person isn't your friend that
person is dragging you down find people
that make you feel good
hello everybody welcome back to the show
it is a half a million subscriber q a
episode which i
that's a lot of people that i do not
know what to think about that many
people subscribe to this channel but
thank you to everyone who has supported
the show who continues to share the
episodes and tell your friends to tune
in and thank you for putting up with
what feels like weekly q a episodes at
the moment as well but you know life's
hard when you're flying high and
rattling through subscribers so what can
i say uh as usual i ask for questions
from twitter youtube locals instagram
and we got a lot i'm gonna try and get
through as many as i can so
here we go
liz willems dear chris
is it just me or does it always seem
like you're always sitting at an angle
uh so yes it does i suppose it does seem
like that but i'm actually
stood up i'm standing up and because i
have a little
stool underneath this desk i put one
foot on it and stand to the side anyone
that does use a standing desk i highly
recommend getting a little stool you
want it to be about sort of six inches
or so maybe tiny little bit more if you
stand with one foot on the floor and one
foot on the stool it'll alleviate a lot
of the tension in your lower back so
that's why very very well noticed
j colin 17. i'm reading the expectation
effect loving it what should i read next
so i have a list of 100 books that you
should read before you die and you can
get it here or if you go to
chriswilx.com
books it's books that i love there's
summaries and there's links you can go
and buy them and there's explanations
about why i enjoyed them and there's
fiction and non-fiction and you should
go and get it i would recommend if you
enjoyed the expectation effect by david
robson who was an awesome guest on this
podcast you can go and listen to that um
the ape who understood the universe by
steve stewart williams will take your
face off evolutionary psychology
understanding why we are the way we are
basis of human nature
if you enjoyed the sort of human naturey
conversations on the channel the ape who
understood the universe will blow you
away but get the reading list because
it's in there and then you'll just get a
big list of them all
omar kharam7
is gary vee on your radar for a podcast
i'm not i'm not massively familiar with
gary's work i'm not a huge not like a
huge hater or anything i'm just not a
huge fan of his stuff i've
i don't really know what to talk to him
about i don't know what his new thing is
i knew he was into nfts for a big while
uh maybe i guess but he's not
it's not someone that i'm actively
seeking out
sammy dalio how many hours do you read a
day so i think a lot of people
have this misconception that i spend a
lot of time reading
i really struggle to find time to read
apart from what i need to do for the
show because the show is super
aggressive at three episodes a week
usually sometimes even four if i need to
play catch up or do whatever
a lot of the time i'm just blasting
through the book of the guest that i've
got that's coming on or i'm making notes
or doing whatever
what i have taken to doing a lot
recently is
reading more articles than books in my
leisure time reason for that is that i
find articles just cut to the chase of
what it is that they're trying to get to
a lot of the time more quickly uh center
kindle for chrome is an extension you
can get and it turns any web page into a
kindle optimized document and then
immediately sends it to your kindle so
instead of using a relator app like
pocket or instapaper just press one
button on the top corner of google
chrome and whatever web page your new
york times posts or something on sub
stack or medium or whatever and then it
just appears on your kindle so what i do
is i press that on whenever someone
sends me something that looks
interesting send it over and then
whenever i open my kindle up i've just
got this backlog of
you know five to twenty minute long
reads that i can go through whenever i
want it's on there it's held in your
kindle library it's an absolute game
changer hours that i read per day i
would say at maximum one
uh but it's one quite intense hour
usually split up into like 10 minute
sections
dior
terry d or t rick
what's your take on andrew tate's ban
while i don't want to silence people
isn't his rhetoric harmful um
my take on his band is that i'm not
surprised i texted him i whatsapped him
the other day and basically said the
same like you fly too close to the sun
and
social media platforms will find a way
to get rid of you uh yeah i mean does he
say stuff that could quite easily be
seen as something that contravenes a
particular type of community guideline
across most of those platforms yeah
probably
um
i don't know i mean
the value judgment of whether or not he
should be taken off is a much bigger
conversation because it's around what
what other platforms rules should those
rules be the rules the bottom line my
take on tatespan is it was always in the
post he was never going to be allowed to
continue to grow and proliferate with
that kind of message for that long so
bottom line is i'm not surprised and
it'll be interesting to see what he does
next
joe
w245 let's [ __ ] go boy
can you talk about your approach to
meditation please yes so
i've done about maybe a thousand
sessions ish of meditation maybe 1200.
uh the first
500 that i ever did was a mix of
it pretty much was exclusively headspace
uh andypudikon from that if you need an
intro to meditation it's great i'm sure
that there'll be three months that you
can grab online and referrals and stuff
like that if you're a student in the uk
you can get spotify your spotify
membership gets discount and you get
free headspace for the year with it as
well
um after that i switched to something
called shinzen young's five ways to know
yourself which if you google that
is a pdf and it is the most simple
rationally written science-based
solution for how to meditate that i've
ever read and i followed that i also got
a coach a guy called brian maniscalco
who is specializes in five ways and he
coached me through that so i did about
500 sessions of guided and then around
about whatever 700 sessions of unguided
following five ways
10 minutes to 20 minutes in the morning
mostly i think my average session length
on insight time is about 13 minutes
um i do it as a part of my morning
routine get up go for a walk come back
sit down journal meditate
read a book
do some rehab get up and do my day
that's the easiest way to do it just put
it in as a part of your morning routine
and
i enjoy it it's a big part of my life
deep fried films
seen you post some random comments
alluding to being autistic true question
mark how do you navigate this so this is
me playing a little bit fast and loose i
think with
that uh
everyone is who is slightly socially
awkward i think kind of lasered at the
feet of oh like can't can't i didn't
mean to say that bro i didn't mean to
offend you like it's just the autism
coming through um
i
maybe maybe there is a smidge in there
i've never been diagnosed i definitely
don't want to appropriate uh autistic
culture that being said i do believe i
tweeted this the other day that micro
dosing autism is a performance enhancer
because
the one of the biggest competitive
advantages you can have in the modern
world is to be a little bit obsessive
over one narrow domain to be
detail-focused and detail-oriented
this isn't for me to say that we should
be trying to find how to make people
autistic uh but my point is that i think
there are a lot of traits i i see a lot
of the guys that i'm i'm in a degenerate
degenerate autistics group chat uh of a
bunch of people here in austin all of
these guys are absolute hitters they're
all complete killers they're all super
successful at whatever they do and i'm
like okay well there's something going
on here uh yeah i don't know with
regards to me i just
try to get over the introversion that is
innate that's the biggest part of it
that and a bit of social awkwardness but
i think being an only child kind of just
leans you toward that in any case
because you're under socialized so is it
autism or is it being an only child like
or is it both i don't know
evan gd can we get the video feed on
spotify
okay so
spotify now supports
um
video rogues is on there obviously lex
friedman does his on there
um i'm looking at moving hosting
platform for what i use for the audio uh
to something else nothing will change
for all of the people that listen to the
show and actually for everyone that's
watching on youtube the episodes are
available 10 hours earlier on audio so
if you're subscribed on audio you get
you get access to the episode 10 hours
before there's no mid-roll ads that you
have to skip from youtube or any of that
sort of stuff so
you can go and subscribe there are links
in the pin comment below and you can go
and subscribe on apple podcast.spotify
and you'll get access uh super early
with regards to the video spotify thing
it is going to be operationally a lot
more difficult because that means i now
need to have different types of files
for different types of platforms it
means that whatever i upload stuff to
for spotify is going to need to be a
different version for what i upload to
apple podcast because that doesn't
support video basically it's
operationally super difficult
i would be interested to know in the
comments how many people would prefer to
watch video on spotify versus youtube um
i guess post if that's something that
you're interested in and i can start to
look at it frankly it's not going to be
soon
mostly because
we are still still me
and assistant ben and dean um so if we
were to add something in it's one of us
is just going to start eating more [ __ ]
on a daily basis but um
maybe it's something that i would
consider i guess
lfg congrats mate was there ever a point
you considered quitting podcasting if so
what kept you going
not really man i i mean it's only been i
say only it's only been four and a half
years like nearly approaching five five
in february now so yeah four and a half
i guess
i've never thought about stopping ever
um
this is one of the wild things as well
that
because i enjoyed it so much for so long
and did it with basically no one
watching
getting a little bit of positive
feedback or a lot of half a million
people's worth of positive feedback um
now is just encouraging me to do
something that i was already doing when
no one was really watching so
yeah i i never considered um i i love
doing this i enjoy having the
conversations and
as the show grows i get more
opportunities to do different things i
can push the cultural conversation in
different ways i can give platforms to
people that are
amazing but haven't yet been discovered
like it's just everything's getting
better it's at the moment it's amazing
and in the past i didn't have a problem
so
fingers crossed i i don't encounter any
problems in motivation and i just
continue to
chew through
feminists
will you explore different formats eg
co-hosts panel discussions live shows on
stage etc um so yeah i i've considered
doing live shows there's been a lot of
requests for them and stuff i got a bit
of imposter syndrome around that like
who
who am i to ask people to come to some
show and then hear me speak on stage
what am i going to talk about i'm not
really a specialist in anything other
than asking other people questions and i
can't really ask myself questions on
stage so and i don't want to talk about
podcasting i would not want to do a
podcast about podcasting i found that
my least favorite type of conversation
is when i go on a show and they want to
ask me about the process of podcasting
and
asking questions and stuff like that i
would much sooner be treated as someone
that just has opinions about a topic or
an insight or whatever um yes i would
love to uh co-host i still got johnny
and yusuf they do the um life hacks
episodes with me and zack tallander my
roommate comes on pretty regularly panel
discussions and live shows potentially
down the line uh i i don't know how big
the audience is in america versus uk now
it's probably 50 50 maybe even slightly
more skewing toward america at least on
youtube it's more uk on audio a little
bit i think point being there's not one
place that i could go and be like yeah
there's definitely you know 500 people
that would come to a show but again if
people want a live show then
uh i'd be more than happy to do it i
would love to record one in vr i really
want to do a podcast in virtual reality
so that you could put a headset on and
you would sit there and if you turned
and looked to the left you'd be able to
see me and if you turned the look to the
right you'd be able to see the guest i
think that would be really really cool
so i'm kind of speaking to some of the
guys behind rec room which is this vr
organization to see if they can
facilitate that but
yeah uh
wait and see
uh nathaniel what are you more proud of
500 000 subscribers or 500 000 through
the doors
cobble wobble okay so
um
cobble wobble was something that i came
up with with my business partner when we
were running a saturday club night that
had a huge
football pitch sized cobbled um front to
it and girls that go out in newcastle
tend to wear quite high heels and as you
would see them [ __ ] hell this was so
funny you would see them walking from
a long way 150 yards away you could see
them and they would hit these cobbles
and it would just be them desperately
trying to keep themselves up so we sort
of called it the cobble wobble and um
i i mean i've done a million
uh
entries through the doors across my
career of club promoting so i've
actually got fewer subs than i do uh
entries and it's very different right
all of the stuff that i did throughout
my 20s with darren at voodoo i'm just so
proud of and it set me up to to do this
moving forward um
i'm equally proud of both at the moment
but i've got a long way to go i need to
double the number of subs in order to
meet the number of entries so we'll see
how i feel then
nate mchugh at what point did it click
and decided to stop drinking at what
point did it click
and decided to stop drinking what did
you replace drinking with exercise
reading love your podcast okay so andrew
human shared a tweet
a clip a quote of mine that is alcohol
is the only drug where if you don't do
it people assume you have a problem and
it went absolutely insane online so
sobriety's been such a huge part of my
life for a long time now that it
it almost feels like
i i can't remember what life was like
before that one of the big things that i
do remember is i used to have this
friday afternoon itch so it would get to
maybe 2 or 3 p.m on a friday and they'd
be just i don't know it was it's like
being hungry but it was for partying i'd
you know i'd want to listen to some
house music and like get the beers in
with the boys and get ready to go out
and stuff
um
i wanted to make a change toward the end
of my 20s i knew that i needed more time
more money more calories more
consistency if i wanted to do that i
kept on getting frustrated that every
time i started a habit
i would
break it and i always used to think that
my mood was all over and my sleep was
all over and
the hangovers for me would knock me not
just out of
kilter for that one day but then my
routine the amount of time it would take
me to get back into that was just so so
disheartening
and as soon as i stopped all of those
problems went away
so
it clicked as soon as i started as soon
as i did my first month of
focus sobriety um which was a part of a
new year
plan as well so i had a new training
regime i replaced it with
more work basically the podcast came
into that after
six months i think or maybe 12 months
um a lot of personal development i got
into reading right i got into meditation
i got into breath work i got into doing
uh a morning routine with walking in and
more consistent training and stuff it
just opened up all of the things i
wanted to do and it was nothing flash or
glamorous you know i wasn't going out
wake surfing or something instead i was
still just doing the normal thing in
newcastle but yeah it's
if you're struggling and you need to
make a big change cutting out drinking
is a very very very good place to start
jerome sanders congrats question
whenever i see the news it's all doom
and gloom how do you stay on top of
current affairs and yet have a positive
optimistic outlook of the future i'm not
convinced i've got a positive optimistic
outlook of the future i am british and
we are sort of perennially uh
dour sometimes
i don't treat the current affairs with
much personal investment i don't believe
most of the headlines they are
designed to limitly hijack you not
transmit information to you
so you need to see them for what they
are which is
like wwe characters
made into words and put on screen
um not taking it too seriously knowing
that you only have control over the way
that you behave and the immediate
environment that you have
um that you interact with
i'm focusing on that um you know you
have got to this stage and you're
absolutely fine everything all of the
worries all the concerns all of the late
nights and the neuroses and the
overthinking and the thought loops and
everything
and yet here you are listening to this
podcast
what gives you the sense that that's not
going to continue you have however many
years you've been alive of evidence that
any challenge that you face you're fine
with
and yet because of negativity bias we're
concerned about the future don't take it
too seriously we're all going to die in
any case
most of the news is
[ __ ]
created larping by a media class that
doesn't care about you or transmitting
information effectively
uh that's a good a
good panacea i think
alessandro belli congrats chris do you
use any productivity or organizational
software to run your podcast okay so my
full
uh productivity stack um is
omnifocus as my to-do list manager apple
notes for all of my notes taking notion
for a little bit of collaborative stuff
between me and assistant ben
uh google docs for a collaborative stuff
between me and video guy dean and
facebook messenger for me
me and dean to go back and forth about
edits and stuff like that first off i
know that that is a lot of different
platforms that i'm using secondly i know
that i'm using most of them
for
uh duplicate purposes and even with
messenger for purposes that it's not
built for why am i not using slack or
something else
i went through a period especially the
beginning of the podcast you can go back
and listen to episodes that were like
really focused on dialing in
productivity and different types of
pomodoro techniques and peter c brown on
make it stick in the science of
interleaved uh
space repetition and the ebbing house
forgetting curve and all this [ __ ]
and i think that it's important to
dedicate yourself to a period of that so
that you kind of understand the physics
of how productivity works but over time
i just settled back into a minimum
effective dose and also the most
frictionless way if you use a platform
which even takes five or ten percent
more willpower is a bit more clunky or
isn't as natural to you
you are going to be less efficient on
that than a platform which is
significantly more built for purpose but
takes a ton more willpower to use so
simply by
uh the process of emergence i've landed
on the particular stack that i've got i
would highly recommend using apple notes
if you are looking for a note-taking app
yeah it doesn't have all of the tools
and stuff that notion does but it is
rapid it's immediately across all of
your devices it's never once broken on
me which is super super important
um
omnifocus is good i'm actually going to
switch to things three when i get some
time so if you're looking for to-do list
manager things three or omnifocus are
both good omnifocus is very advanced and
things three is a little bit more uh
normal to use
what else do i have
that's pretty much it a lot of this
stuff is kind of uh
thrown into apple notes and then i i
just filter through stuff notes for
newsletter or notes for an episode or
guest ideas or whatever just dump it in
there and that's one other advantage
there's probably a better way for me to
you know have a seamless capture process
as part of my gtd method but if i just
put everything into apple notes it ends
up being found
jj love seeing the growth man thank you
do you think we'll ever see a podcast
with hamza or first man in the future i
think there's a lot of value in their
content that many people need to see and
you'd be able to help with that and add
more insight to their ideas and ideals
again keep up the great work thank you
jj i did a podcast with hamza uh it will
be linked up here and it will be in the
show notes below for the people that
want to check it out
uh hamza is absolutely crushing it at
the moment i mean
i think when we both spoke back end of
last year we were on maybe 200
ish k each 200 to 250 and this is 500
for me i think he's on 700 now he's
absolutely crushing we speak relatively
infrequently over whatsapp he's the
worst whatsapp replier uh sorry hamza
i'm outing you here but dude you are
terrible at replying on whatsapp
that being said i love what he's doing i
think that he
really does
he accesses an area that i wouldn't be
able to speak to specifically of sort of
men masculinity that sort of pro guy
holistic self-improvement movement uh
just because he's a bit younger and also
he's he's really sort of leaned into
that
red pill black pill manosphere culture
and then repurposed it on its head to
kind of show some of the ridiculous
outcomes that people have there i think
the stuff that he's doing is is really
really good and
he messaged me the other day saying that
we might do a live stream soon on his
youtube so if that happens just keep
your eyes peeled on his channel we'll
probably have him back on at some point
soon too
josh gonzalez do you feel any different
now than when you only had 50k or even
5k subs i'm wondering how things have
changed for you internally externally
with new commitments and
responsibilities
yeah so that's a good question
um do i feel any different
not really because the experience of
doing the show has always been me in a
room staring to a camera right it's
slightly nicer camera slightly different
mic slightly better lighting slightly
different country but
it's always been the same thing
and
the numbers on the screen of how many
people watch or listen or or message or
whatever
they don't have the same sort of impact
as seeing it in real life the the
biggest change is when i go out into the
real world every so often and see people
that listen to the show and
they come up and
bring up something that happened on an
episode or ask me a question that's wild
that feels
i don't know like this computer game
that i've been playing is actually
affecting the real world somehow so
remembering that is important one of the
other things i'm thinking about more
i mentioned it earlier on is
there's an opportunity to
guide the way that people think the way
that the culture moves what people focus
on the sort of people that are given a
platform
and and that is so exciting to me it's
really really really exciting to think
that
some
i mean will costello is a good example
of gwinderbogle right either of them are
great examples
fantastic fascinating
humans with tons and tons of value to
add
and
not enough people know about them as far
as i'm concerned
i enjoy speaking to them i think that
works fascinating
and because of work that i've put in in
the past and the audience that has faith
in what i've put out previously
this is now an opportunity for them to
boost their exposure because they're
brilliant they just haven't played the
clickbait game sufficiently well or
whatever the exposure the online
exposure game to get themselves an
audience yet yeah that's that's the
coolest thing that's the biggest
difference other than that it's just the
same man i send files to dean i research
people that i'm interested in i sit in
my room and i read
books or articles or listen to podcasts
or speak to other podcasters or do
whatever
and then i come in here and have a
conversation like it really is cool that
the
input hasn't changed me to mike and
camera but the out come on the other
side is totally different uh it would be
a lot stranger if i know it was playing
in front of a live audience or something
but yeah at the moment everything's like
nicely uh
status chloe
sky king where do you want to go for
dinner so
uh where did we go last night flower
child went to flower child in downtown
austin and then came back here and
watched both episodes of lords of the
rings um that was where we went he was
asking me this on twitter yesterday but
i missed it so
he chose he was good
strady123
how did you go about finding guests when
you first started your podcast exactly
the same way that i do now do i see
someone on the internet i think is
interesting have i read a book where i
think that the author's got something
cool to say
have i noticed an article online
have i listened to a podcast on someone
else's show where this guy or girl has
absolutely smashed it that's it it's
just always me there's no one else that
does my booking for me it's always me
it's always been me
um
i'm pretty sure that rogan does all of
his own booking as well uh which is
wild there are shows
of my size shows that smaller than my
size and definitely ones in between me
and rogan
who have full-time guest bookers so
the curation of people that are going on
to their show is done by somebody else
and that's fine
if that's the sort of show that you want
but
i feel like to be
completely existentially connected with
what you're putting out on the internet
one of the most important things is who
comes on the show why are they on there
what are the sort of questions that you
ask what's the sort of angle that you're
going after
and if i was to find out that one of my
favorite creators didn't choose the
people that came on the show i think i
would feel a little bit
disheartened because
i hope that that person is like a museum
curator right i step into the hallowed
halls of wherever it is that they're
running their podcast today
and that they've selected all of the
different things that are on the walls
all of the exhibits that's not the case
for everybody but i'm very glad that
it's the case for me
uh
astrovert108 when will you write a book
ah good question
there there are um
some people who are waiting with baited
breath for me to give them that answer i
don't know man like there's been book
offers and they're very
generous and uh incredibly flattering
and there's just something about i don't
know whether it's imposter syndrome
maybe making me worried there was
something else about i felt earlier on
this year when there was really serious
conversation happening about it
just like i should focus on the show
more
uh and keep on driving as
good episodes as i can
over a long period of time
and
sure enough it ended up paying off
because
i would have had to sacrifice a lot of
stuff on the show in order to write the
book uh or i had to write a pretty
half-assed book
to have kept going with the level of
output for the show so i think i'm going
to continue to focus on the show for a
little while um
i would love to write a book that's kind
of like the
um lessons episodes i've done i did i
think one for number 400 and one for 500
as well um i would love to condense that
down like a broly 12 rules for life i
suppose um but taken from stuff that
i've learned on the show so it's a cross
between tools of titans from tim
and you know a 12 rulesie type thing
uh i would i think that that would be
pretty cool
and i would love writing it and it would
be a great development tool for me to
recap all of the stuff that i've learned
and it would nicely round out my journey
i think from you know whatever five
years ago until now but right now just
full steam ahead on modern wisdom
attila
are you a liberal or conservative
i i don't think that
i would fall into either of those
categories i think that
as soon as you start attaching labels to
yourself like that you are heading down
a pretty dangerous road i definitely
have a lot of conservative values
culturally
but not necessarily when it comes to the
hardcore policy and politics and stuff
like that does that mean that you're a
conservative i don't know like your
cultural values are more important than
your actual political affiliation now
you know if you are
um
financially liberal and
uh pro-choice
but don't believe and agree with
progressively wokey agendas and that
three-year-olds should be able to choose
their own
gender uh that means apparently that
you're a conservative which is kind of
strange right because
conservatism and uh progressivism or
like left and right were typically
around about class it was a distinction
between class
but now it's not it's a distinction
between culture and whoever which team
you're film fingering for more
rowan charland advice for surviving uni
i
did a video
four years ago called how to survive
university and you can search it you can
find it if you just put how this five
university chris williamson and it'll
come up
the main things were
treat uni like a job so do your nine to
five get up go to the library or
lectures or do whatever
and just treat it like a job that's all
you need to do you don't need to do that
many hours you're going to have tons of
free periods you can train during the
middle of it but just treat it like a
job and nothing will go wrong
other than that
find a group of friends that you really
get on with i would highly recommend
that you
start working for a promotions company
reason being that they'll give you a
ready set group of friends who will care
about you and are all got similar
interests to you
if you are going to newcastle or leeds
or birmingham or
manchester i think that's pretty much it
uh just message voodoo events dot co uk
go on there message them say that i sent
you and they will interview you and have
a look at you for a job and they would
be amazing to work for especially if
you're going to newcastle you have to go
to work for voodoo
um other than that
find a sports team that you can get
involved in one of the things i regret
from my time at uni is that i didn't
take more advantage of doing stuff like
ultimate frisbee or be a part of the
golf society or the whatever society
because i thought that was kind of lame
but what i realized was that it was a
great those are the things now that i go
out of my way to go and do i'll ask a
friend if he wants to go play disc golf
or if we can go and learn how to play
pickleball or something like that and
there's probably a society you need for
it so join societies liberally try and
find a job ideally a promotion company
or something similar maybe working in a
bar the bar's kind of compared with
promo uh treat uni like a job those
would be three pieces of advice
george j kennedy what is your
relationship like with junk food uh
interestingly the last time i did a
a uh q a
i got lambasted for drinking diets dr
pepper and also accused of being
sponsored i'm not sponsored by dr pepper
but if you do want to sponsor me
i'll happily take your money
that being said i've put much worse
things in my body than the diet dr
pepper for the people who are concerned
about my health i appreciate your input
but i was a club promoter for 15 years
and if the worst thing that i've ever
put into my body is a diet dr pepper
i'll be very surprised relationship with
junk food i tend to
i've been i've been getting better a lot
this year
the last couple of years um
i do like sweet things i've got a sweet
tooth
uh chocolate bars and like outright
sweets and stuff like that a little bit
less but
raspberry crumbles from whole foods or
you know like granola bowls of cereal i
usually finish most meals with something
sweet which is probably a pretty bad
habit for me to get into
but bulking bro or something i don't
know what my excuse is there i probably
should be better with it but
i don't know i
i work very hard and use up um
a good bit of effort on lots of other
things and i feel like the enjoyment
that i get from letting go of that in
other areas specifically around like
treats uh probably helps me to keep on
working hard elsewhere
fritz dot dvl your fan base now could
easily become a nation state yes
yes the nation of modern wisdom could
you imagine that
what would our flag look like
i don't know i'll get someone to design
a flag and then we can just become a
nation state balaji was all about
splitting off what was it the network
states he's about that we basically are
a nation state you know you and your the
people that you follow online you have a
lot more in common with them than
sometimes you do with your domestic
culture so maybe there's an argument to
be made that we already are
gaz man what was peter teal like in
person do you think he will come on your
show so i did a live discussion
facilitated a live discussion between
peter thiel and alex epstein
in uh lido isle in uh newport near
newport beach california
peter's cool guy he is very smart he is
he pays attention which i very much
appreciate
he gave me his attention as well after
he'd finished up doing the discussion
i do think he'll probably come on the
show uh at some point i need to reach
out and put a little pitch over to him
but
i'll be very interested to speak to him
i mean he's you know he's a formative
guy whether you believe that he's the
the dark lord gateway drug to the
alt-right or whatever like
he's a an influential figure and
continues to be so yes i would i would
be interested to try and dig into that
brain of his
lump oh cole chris i think you might be
the greatest nightclub promoting
anthropologist i've ever seen it's
awesome to see light up when you discuss
human evolution and psychology well
thank you lump uh
yes the
evolutionary psychology stuff at the
moment just blows my head off i've got
the next period that you're going to see
will be a probably quite heavy into
human nature uh uncovering um
intrasexual competition so female to
female in male to male competition more
dating dynamic stuff um more human
behavior stuff
i just adore it i i get endlessly
fascinated uncovering this stuff and
every time that i have a conversation
there is something that i
like i relish it gives me a sense you
know if you've ever played baseball or
cricket you hit the ball out of the
middle of the bat that's the same
sort of satisfaction i get when robin
dunbar tells me about why
it's so hard for women to get pregnant
because it forced pairs to have sex more
which caused them to bond more which
meant that eventually when the woman did
get pregnant they had a better pair bond
which meant that they would stay
together to look after the kid
just go
that
is
so interesting
and yeah
the more that i get to talk about it the
better
lj lj22 excellent work congratulations
thank you my question is a new global
government is installed and having heard
your conversations about topics relating
to men and masculinity they appoint you
as their first minister for men the
manister if you will i'm damn right the
manister has to create a manifesto yes
which details the ideas and views of the
new regime what do you list as the three
biggest issues facing men in today's
society and what three actions would you
advocate to improve their current
situation
so
easy for these three
first one lowering levels of
testosterone second one
social isolation third one lack of
ability to find a partner
first one
in terms of actions for this would be
get every man
conscripted to train every man has to
train it doesn't have to be weight
training it could be any form of
physical exercise but there has to be
some type of progressive overload there
has to be some type of external
accountability slash motivation in a
group
setting uh and they also have to learn
the fundamentals of health and fitness
like the fact that people go through
school and learn about
algebra but don't understand how to diet
down or what muscle building can do for
you is just completely wild uh what was
the second one social isolation okay so
that would be fixed in part at least by
them having a group that they would go
and train with uh i think that more
men's
shed style
communities which is similar to what max
dickens was talking about a couple of
weeks ago where you give men a
project that they work on together and
they end up bonding over that it seems
like men's friendships are predicated on
working together on a task as opposed to
kind of convenience or comfort or
emotions and stuff
they bond
through doing the task through fixing
the car or building the fence or
whatever
and finally in terms of dating
difficult one i think that
teaching men the fundamentals of
evolutionary psychology is important
i think that teaching men how easy it is
to raise your mate value it's
significantly easier for men to raise
their mate value than women women are
stuck with the bodies and the faces and
the age that they have and they get some
cosmetic surgery or wear some makeup and
kind of hope for the best guys can
change their status their money
significantly easier
empowering men to believe that that's
the case and showing them just how
little work it takes in order for them
to get ahead that would be important
paul campbell you've talked about doing
work that doesn't always feel like work
being a competitive advantage what is an
area of work where you can handle the
pain better than those around you
that is a good question col uh and
that's because carl has a podcast
himself
um
i think
being able to work on my own is
a
superpower of mine that i've got
relative to most of the people there
will be many people that can work more
but
i can grind out on a project
consistently over time
pretty well uh and doing things as a
marathon you know running a night
nightlife stuff was really really
difficult and it was every single week i
missed no saturdays for 204 weeks in a
row 204 saturdays without a single break
and the only time that i did have a
break was because i'd got a
chest infection or lung infection or
something and it was basically bed
ridden
um
yeah i think being able to work on your
own
the ability to be solitary and
self-managed is a complete
game changer for most people
having executive function where you can
choose what you're going to do and then
go and do it like being both the
organ
grinder and the monkey being both the
boss and the employee of yourself is a
really good skill to learn
change my mind podcast how can you defy
the gravitational meat the gravitational
pull
of mediocrity the average creates
that's also a good question um so i
understand what you mean that in any
group of people the most likely type of
performer that you're going to have
around you will be average because the
bell curve suggests that you're going to
have
you're going to have a lot of those
people need you
this kind of relates to the previous
uh point which is that
you can
choose to be a little bit of a lone
ranger if you can cultivate that in
yourself
and if you can
decide what the outcomes are that you
want to have in life and then kind of
begin to ruthlessly cull the things that
don't contribute to that so if you're
around people and every time that you
step away from this person let's say you
go for dinner with them or you catch up
with them or whatever you just find
yourself feeling agitated or upset or
depressed or angry or frustrated or
whatever that person isn't your friend
that person is dragging you down should
we see our friends as
a commodity that we should invest in or
not no we shouldn't and should we
support friends even if they're going
through a bad time yes we absolutely
should but if this person that
personality just happens to be a dick
and as a byproduct of you being around
them you feel like a dick as well
just don't spend any more time with them
find people that make you feel good
other things you can do is
follow online creators that
speak to you so this was the big change
for me because 2016 or whatever i start
to see sam harris and alanda bottom from
the school of life and jordan peterson
and rogan and
all of these people having conversations
that made me feel like my capacity maybe
i had more agency right over the
outcomes i had in life so i created a
community of people around me virtually
that weren't the average that were
genuine outliers and that were teaching
me things i really cared about so you
can do it by curating what you consume
very carefully but
you know you can't get away from the
fact that we need physical in-person
uh input from people
so
call the people that don't give you
energy and
fine to people that do
insta redza
have you got plans to hit a ut longhorns
game or
acl this year so yeah i would um i would
love to go to a longhorns game i haven't
seen any sport except for one rugby
match since i've been here and i adore
going to live sport so anyone that's in
austin that has suggestions for where i
should go let me know acl i will be
there that's the start of october i
think i might actually try and do a
meet-up in acl that would be pretty fun
we could do a little ravy meet-up there
uh but yeah zack my uh housemate has got
i think he's even got some friends that
may be playing so we're definitely gonna
be there i'll see you at acl
robo clock
thoughts on young men and boys being
indoctrinated by the red pill community
so
i understand why
it is a seductive
ideology
to adhere to to believe in
to consume as well
the red pill and the black pill to me
are getting closer and closer together
um
[Music]
i'm seeing less and less in the red pill
community
of the agentic sovereign individual pick
yourself up by your bootstraps world and
more of the i am immutable
uh
human and the world must be mutable
around me so women need to fix the
hypergamy but i'm not going to date
older women hang on a second you're
saying that they have to get past their
biological predisposition but you're not
going to get past yours that doesn't
seem very right
the young men and boys being
indoctrinated into it does concern me
because a lot of the time when you are
young you learn by experimenting and
just doing things so you will
find out what it's like to drive for an
hour and a half to meet a chick and she
doesn't turn up like that's a lesson
that is kind of important for you to
learn
in person not just read it on a reddit
post right or hear a story about it on a
podcast it's important for you to feel
like it's also important for you to feel
like
what it's like to get into a
relationship with a girl
and
you fall out of love with her and then
you have to work out okay so how do i
break up with someone as opposed to
reading it on the internet like it is
important for you to learn these things
in the real world if you look at most
most of the
conclusions that people
on red pill groups are talking about it
is a handful of people who've had
genuine experience ventriloquizing
groups of people who do not have
experience and who have vicariously
lived dating lives through their online
creators
that is not the world that you're
supposed to be in in my experience and i
have met a lot of women throughout my
time right i've met over half a million
girls just stood on the front door of
nightclubs
they are
for almost the entire part
warm caring lovely
some of them are immature some of them
are mature some of them you would want
to date some of them you definitely
wouldn't want to date but they're just
they're normal humans and then you read
this stuff online that makes them sound
like an army of robots ready to try and
take down any man that goes near them
and the same thing for women to men like
you know the
women's view of men is i would say maybe
in fact it is worse you know
men are viewed as worse agents by women
than women are viewed by men but even in
the red pill world uh yeah there's a lot
of work that needs to be done i'm
concerned by it and this is why i
mentioned it earlier on i think that
there needs to be a third wave
manusphere movement uh first wave being
pickup artistry second wave being uh red
pill and third wave being whatever comes
next that
where we can have a non-adversarial a
collaborative
um
world view of what men and women are
like dave we've worked together
literally in partnership for hundreds of
thousands of years and now we're on
different teams now we're tribally on
different teams that's not the way that
it should be as far as i can see
boss abaron
does your family support your work yes
so family isn't uh
particularly big for me it's me and mum
and dad but they
do very much support my work um
mum listens to most episodes dad
listens when there's something that
piques his interest and he drives a lot
so he catches up then um yeah they've
always been super supportive that's
something that they got completely right
i think they
knew
that i wasn't
a destined for perhaps
whatever predetermined path they might
have thought and rather than
getting concerned about that they put a
lot of faith in me and just allowed me
to go and do my things this is why it
feels so strange when i hear about
people that make decisions because of
what their parents would want them to do
she would mum would want me to marry a
dot dot doctor lawyer
somebody somebody uh i've taken this
degree because dot dot
dad wanted me to go into business or
[ __ ] agriculture like he did or
whatever
very strange dynamic that i'm not
familiar with and very
thankful for as well
coach josh lancaster how often do you
drink alcohol now and use caffeine what
makes the event worthy
so drinking alcohol is pretty rare um
i had a period while i was in austin of
maybe going
every weekend for about a month
uh because there was pool parties and
new interesting things to do
now
in austin i can't remember the last time
that i drank maybe two months something
like that uh but even if i do it'll be
like a beer
partly because when i went sober for so
long i completely reset my tolerance for
alcohol so after
it let's i'm flying back to the uk
tomorrow
i will have one glass of something on
that plane
and you know that'll be me with a nice
little buzz on sat working away on my
laptop for a couple of hours so
that's funny caffeine i have begun um
integrating that more more as a training
uh tool i'm not using it outside of
training i'm also drinking
here's a shout out for you jocko go
which is his
uh energy drink and it is
he gave me one while we were sat down
recording go back and watch the episode
you can watch me pick it up and and
drink it
but it only has 90 milligrams of
caffeine in which is
i think most like a bang energy is 300
or 350 and noco is 1 80. so it's half of
a knuckle
uh it's got a bunch of l-theanine in it
it's got no
basically no sugar everything's natural
it's pasteurized so that all of the
nasty additives that get put in there
says the guy that's drinking the dr
pepper yeah i know whatever but
it tastes good you can get it on amazon
there's one called mango mayhem there's
a new
flavor release across the entire range
and mango mayhem is available at least
in the us
it's amazing so that before training
just makes me feel so good and
especially if i want if i'm in an uber
the back of the back of the uber is the
driver is trying to speak to me and i'm
like having to pause the music every
couple of seconds because i don't know
whether he's finished speaking or not uh
listening to that with a little bit of
caffeine kicking in when i'm super
sensitive to it is just such a buzz i
love it
um but yeah i mean the event being
worthy is
basically few and far between which is
which is what it should be it shouldn't
be the case that you need to drink in
order to feel
normal or happy or competent or socially
unanxious and stuff
as soon
as a substance stops affording you a
benefit it has now become a crutch
as soon as the substance stops affording
you a benefit it has now become a crutch
that you are relying on it's not helping
you you need it in order to perform
that's not an assistance anymore
thank you alex homozy for the insight
nab bill pausing
just starting to get into the investment
world now what would you say is the best
place to start okay so i am
i am mr bro signs when it comes to
investing i remember one of the first
investments i ever did was in activision
because the new call of duty was coming
out in 2015 or 16 or something so i had
hopped onto etoro and dumped a bunch of
money into activision and it went up and
i was like oh brilliant and then it went
down and i lost money and i thought this
isn't for me
i only have my money in terms of
investments proper financial investments
which is what i'm going to think you're
getting at in the s p 500 i've got
some
some cash in bitcoin i think through
coinbase
or else i got money
that's it that's it that an s p and then
i've got real estate uh in the uk
but real estate massive fan of s p 500
if you can if you're in the uk you can
get a tax-free investment isa 20 grand a
year is the allowance you know if that
gains at eight percent per year
after 10 20 years that's going to be a
big chunk of change
uh so
that's minimum viable product for me
mr fodd
hillaria
what are the biggest motivators in a man
to do the hard stuff
hmm
well a lot of them can come from places
like status and ego and
a desire for
recognition conquering you know like and
these aren't necessarily things that we
should be too quick to cast off it's all
well and good talking about the
spiritual ego dissolved bro that's done
75 sessions of ayahuasca and has come
back and his consciousness is one with
the astral realm
but if you get
motivation to do something that's good
for you and good for the world and the
motivation happens to come from a place
that's more egoic than you might like
what do you want to do say i'm not going
to do the thing despite the fact that
i've been given free motivation to go
and do it no obviously not you should go
and do the thing um i do really
subscribe to jocker willing's view
though that
discipline eats motivation for breakfast
and that
looking at
designing things consciously in advance
and then once you've decided to do them
just doing them that seems to cut
through a lot of it because
if you are
at the mercy of your motivation things
are going to ebb and flow you might be
motivated to be
in the gym one day and not motivated the
next day okay well if it changes if you
want to stop being a gym guy and want to
be a
coder or something which one's the
correct motivation to follow this isn't
even to do with changes in motivation
level overall which you're also going to
get
um
when it comes to doing hard things
decide in advance that you need to do
them and then when the time comes to do
it remember that you made a commitment
that's it that's what a big chunk of
traditionally being a man is you know
mastery over your environment mastery
over your emotions doing hard things
despite the fact that you don't want to
doing scary things despite the fact that
you're scared that seems like a pretty
good way to contribute to the world as a
man to me
alexander did your interview with louise
perry change your views on casual sex
great podcast bro
yes they did i would say they did i was
already
tumbling down that sort of a path but i
would say that she contributed to it for
sure yeah uh anyone that hasn't listened
to that check out the louise perry
episode on this channel it is
she's fantastic she's very very very
good and i think that decoupling uh sex
from making babies was something that
was uh
at the time
the world didn't understand what
downstream implications that would have
i think it's very difficult to take back
uh like reproductive sovereignty from
women entirely and i don't even know if
that would be desirable
but decoupling sex from emotions around
having sex that's something that
was
probably
culturally even more destructive
because it means that men don't need to
get themselves to the sort of stage that
they need to in order to become worthy
of a woman sleeping with them because
the price or the restrictions that women
have on who they sleep with are less
men will meet the criteria that women
have for them in order to get sex and if
the criteria that women have for them
are low
men will meet those standards
appropriately
do you want to have a society that's
filled with men who have high standards
or low standards
it's a difficult one
felix k what is the right balance
between going with what life throws at
you and creating life according to your
vision
well there is an upper bound on how much
you can do right you can only sail with
the wind it's very difficult for you to
go
i rupture my kellys two years ago if i
had whatever goals i had for going back
to playing cricket that you're out of
the window um i think trying to be too
controlling when it comes to the way
that life goes is is a an error that
being said maximizing your sovereignty
and your ability to be agent is really
important so
you know have a nest egg of money so
that in case something bad happens like
you rub your achilles and you can't work
for a while or whatever or a pandemic
happens that you can
um
that you're not going to be completely
screwed by that
i don't think that there is a
one-size-fits-all balance between going
with what life throws at you and
creating life according to your vision
serendipity will occur and the harder
that you work the luckier that you will
get so just continue to do the things
the highest point of contribution for
you and then as optionality arises
make the decision there and then
things a lot of things will happen if
you do a little bit
a lot of options will come your way if
you put yourself out there because most
people don't put themselves out there
and
yeah the
going with life with what life throws at
you is very very easy to do when you're
moving along a set of uh tracks towards
something that you care about
sonic time tr vlr
i've been thinking about the concept
about people with beauty or looks are
often treated better from verdict at
court to being waited on uh to making
that stupid joke while at the bar
combine this with the talks you have had
about becoming more interesting and more
charismatic with practice do you think
that for some part of the population
that more unattractive someone
that the more unattractive someone is
the more likely charisma is ignored
because of perceived ugliness yeah so
the halo effects a real deal i think and
if you were to have someone that was a
10 out of 10 in humor and a 10 out of 10
in looks the humor is going to be
taken in a better way and their looks
are also going to be interpreted in a
nicer way
i do think that
it is
easier to change your attractiveness i'm
gonna guess this is a guy
i i'm gonna guess that it's
it is easier to change your
attractiveness as a guy
than it is to change your personality or
your charisma charisma will take a good
bit of time but if you spend two months
in the gym
that will have a and you've never
trained before that will have a huge
impact on the way that you feel the way
that you carry yourself you know if you
go and do something like brazilian jiu
jitsu as well the confidence that you
have when you walk into somewhere that
is a
not necessarily
visible it's visible in the way that you
move but it's not visible as in it's
something that'll manifest in your
physique
pretty important so
yeah i i think that you're right you
know
if someone is less good looking then
their charisma is going to be downplayed
but what do you want to do you can't
rail against the world in your genetics
you have to play the cards that you're
dealt
and you know
charisma is relatively
easy to develop according to charlie
hooper from charisma on command he's got
this charisma university i think it's
called um that you could check out if
you wanted to try and develop your
charisma or getting into the gym to make
yourself better looking like
this is this peterson thing recently i
think there's a question
i might get to it oh it's just it's two
questions done i will continue this in
part two uh je romeo that's cool name
i can have a constructive discussion
with people of different political
leanings but i cannot communicate with
people who believe in conspiracy
theories just because evidence facts and
logic do not penetrate their worldview
is there someone you could have as a
guest i assume a psychologist who could
help us at least disarm such a person
conversationally since they're unable to
be persuaded or do we just practice
conflict avoidance with them maybe a
form of verbal jiu-jitsu so
i've had a couple of conversations over
the last year with people who are
explaining about why people believe the
things that they do why um cults and
conspiratorial thinking especially in
the spiritual world
is
resilient shall we say to facts and
logic and pushback and alternative
evidence
one of the other problems that you get
is whenever you bring up the word
conspiracy now
people will say something like well you
know yesterday's conspiracy is today's
true news okay yeah fair enough
when you lose faith in the
organizations that used to have
um that used to hold
reputation
and authority
quite rightly you're going to feel lost
and helpless because you don't you don't
know who to choose you don't know who to
trust
um my
approach is always conflict avoidance uh
it's the i think i mentioned something
earlier on about the fact that i i just
don't take stuff too seriously with
things like that um
it is not my job to help people that
don't want to be helped it is not my job
to try and convince somebody that is so
far gone why why would i i don't care i
don't care enough i care to the ends of
the earth with somebody that's prepared
to do the work that's prepared to help
and change
for the person that is blinkered and
blinded to everything then oh man you're
on your own it's going to make your life
more miserable so i think conflict
avoidance in my opinion is the strategy
same reason i don't reply to troll
comments seriously on twitter
just
if you're going to say something that's
mean then i'm not going to take you as a
serious person if you're going to give
me a considered criticism that's
something that i'll respond to
appropriately
chris le poi de ven
how is it possible for people such as
olivia wilde to so completely
misunderstand the message of jordan
peterson to the point where they think
incels like him do you think it's just
because he has now become such a
lightning rod for anti-woke that is that
his name is a shortcut for virtue
signals to have a shot at chris you have
absolutely nailed it my friend that is
bang on the money i've got a video which
will already be out by now but i
recorded just today with will costello
about this precise thing anybody that
has watched any of jordan peterson's
content knows that incels are not a fan
of him why would they be a fan of
someone that says that they are the
problem they have a non-agentic view of
the world they see both themselves and
the world is immutable that women have
these hypergamous natures that can't be
changed and that they are low mate to
value men who are genetic dead ends and
that also can't change that's the black
pill right
at what point of jordan peterson's
philosophy is that the sort of thing
that he has ever resonated with yes it
is because he is now a representation of
all of the things that are anti-lgbt
anti-progressive that that's that's him
to a nutshell
as it's seen by a lot of the mainstream
media and
the way that it works is
you don't necessarily need the story to
be true you just need other people to
agree about the story and
because most people don't do go and do
original reading olivia why a perfect
example of this right so olivia wilde
said that
the in-cell phenomenon was a group of
angry white
men in cells are disproportionately
represented by people of color
okay
she also said that jordan was a
pseudo-intellectual he's one of the most
cited personality psychologists
ever 88
or a hundred thousand citations on
google scholar
while no it might be eighteen thousand i
might have got that wrong it's a lot
right whatever it is however many it is
it's a hell of a lot thirty years at the
top of the the the um heap when it comes
to personality psychology
her position was not well researched
before she said it
and
the reason that other
news organizations have jumped on it and
continued to promulgate that is that he
represents to a lot of people the
anti-woke pushback and you know he
there's stuff that he's done recently
which kind of draws attention to him in
a way that makes him a little bit easier
to lambast with that so there's a bit of
you made your bed but
he's nothing like what's being portrayed
of him and i think that even the times
when he does do the lightning rod thing
most people have got that wrong as well
i don't think that that's what he means
to say so yeah i don't know it's uh
it'll be very interesting to see
jordan's progression over the uh the
next few months
fella your content is genuinely
life-changing
so proud and keep going thank you
question what advice would you give to
someone 19 years old struggling to find
people to have more meaningful and
fulfilling conversations with because
most of their peers only care about
having conversations about girls alcohol
clubs etc
find older friends
that is
the easiest solution i can think of um
if you are someone that is young and
curious there will be someone who is a
little bit older and curious that would
love to have you as a friend going to
places that have
you know
multi-age range gyms sports teams
uh
clubs libraries stuff like that that
cross more age barriers than most
nightclubs which just tend to be the
young people is a good place to begin
but i i feel you you know it's it's
difficult feeling
alone and another thing as well that i
never had when i was younger
you know 19 to 25 or whatever was this
impression that there was a different
type of world out there
a different type of friend
that i could have the friends that i had
in in newcastle i adored but i had to
work very hard to find them you know
like my business partner darren the only
reason that that was a pure fluke but
god dammit we held on to each other
because you know we were
birds of a feather i suppose and then
johnny and yousef and all of my other
friends i've got in newcastle they were
like hard won i met a million people and
ended up with a still relatively small
pool of friends so you have to put the
work in uh consider trying to find
people that are older than you
consider going to places where those
people would hang out consider going to
places where people like the people that
you would want to be friends with would
be regardless of their age
um those are some the encouragement kid
was there ever a point in your life
where you just thought you'd not make it
and end up being just a regular dude
nine-to-five job broke stressed etc
you're an inspiration keep going
thank you um
i didn't know this was kind of like what
i said earlier on to do with mum and dad
i asked dad this
a while ago and he said something like
he always knew that i wasn't just gonna
go and take a normal job and i thought
well i wish that you told me because i
didn't i
worked you know uh
one summer
at the aaa doing outbound
warm telesales thing that was during a
placement year where i had a bit more
time
there was a period where i was i'd gone
to a
[Music]
careers fair and
really wasn't particularly enamored with
the idea of working for
you know big five consulting companies
or whatever they didn't like to fire in
me but they didn't totally turn me off
either i thought you know maybe
the graduate scheme at little actually
would be fun or whatever i don't know i
i think
i got really lucky by having a lot of
optionality open to me and then maximize
that look by working hard
so
i can't take credit for the opportunity
i can only take credit for
um
maximizing what that opportunity
afforded me
and this is you know one of the ruthless
elements of life that not everybody gets
the opportunity in the first place and
there are many many many people who are
super talented and just don't get that
break
but then there are tons and tons of
people that are talented and get the
break and squander it and that is
precisely where hard work and
consistency will win because
it genuinely does seem to me that the
harder you work the luckier you get and
the more that i continue to do things
consistently at a high
quality over and over again
the easier life gets uh and
i think that it's because a lot of
people really struggle to do that and if
you feel like you want to do something
like you want to make something good
of your life just pick a thing anything
anything and continue to do it for a
period of time a focused period of time
six months i'm going to write a blog
post every week or one year and i'm
gonna produce a youtube video every
fortnight or what would i'm gonna start
doing painting i'm gonna start learning
the guitar whatever it is it's about the
doing the thing not about the thing that
you do at least in the first instance as
you get a bit older yep you need to be
exploring less and exploiting more
but
broadly
no i according to my dad i wasn't just
going to be that i've been broke i was
so broke in the past that i couldn't put
money in the car to go to the
supermarket to buy food and then had i
have gone to buy food i wouldn't have
had any money either um me and darren
had to get a loan from the guy that had
organized our placement yeah while we
were in uh scotland lived in edinburgh
for about six months and um
the
the whole situation was
very
uh
like stressful i suppose uh
and i didn't i i didn't really think of
it about being broke at the time but i
was like there was there was just no
money
and i'd i would not want to go back to
that situation that was probably a
glimpse into a world that i knew that i
really didn't want to have
aaron m congrats chris more than well
deserved thank you
would love to know what insecurity or
weakness you've
had to work at most and what methods or
methods have proved most successful for
you when dealing with it
interesting question
um
what insecurity or weakness
probably the belief that i i wasn't
really meant
to be happy
which is a bit of a sad thing i guess to
admit but
for a very long time i considered myself
to be somebody that had
low mood
depression
that would come in waves you know every
month or every couple of months or
whatever and it's not clinically
diagnosed i did go to the nhs once and
they took they printed out a single
piece of a4 and gave it to me and told
me to go home
but i i just didn't think that i was
supposed to have a particularly
extraordinary life uh not that that's
even something that you should be aiming
for you know the
a lot of the things i enjoy the most at
the moment are kind of simple pleasures
but even just an enjoyable life like it
was just i don't know life was here
i wanted it to be here but i had no idea
how to raise it from where i was to
where i wanted it to be or how to get
there or any of that stuff
um
taking
charge of
convincing myself that i'm the person
that's in control of the direction that
my life goes in
was probably the most important thing
that i did
and
every little step that i took
toward doing something that made me
happier
not only did it actually make me
genuinely create a foundation upon which
i could be happier but it reinforced the
belief that i have control over the
direction that my life goes in right i
don't need to live it by default i can
live it by design
and that becomes a self
perpetuating cycle that makes you better
and better because you have more self
belief which allows you to do more
things which makes you more happy which
gives you myself belief
there you go
so that was probably i i don't think
that
i don't think i thought was supposed to
be a happy person and i still you know
there's still a million
foibles and
failings and shortcomings and
insecurities that i have uh
but i'm so much better
so much better it is it is insane when i
think about the texture of my mind
only five years ago and the sort of
things i used to think about
that would take
charge
of me the concerns that i would have the
i remember
being around friends as well actually is
one being around friends consistently
and understanding what it is to be a
good friend
i've got this app called day one which
is a journaling app
and uh i used it for big life events you
know it wasn't this wasn't the sort of
thing i was writing in daily it would be
uh if mum got ill or or uh i don't know
if i broke up with a girl and i was
conflicted or hurt or whatever it would
be those times so it's like a
bit of a brutal read to go back through
and i remember i put this i don't even
know actually when i wrote it in but
there's at least three or four different
um
diary entries and i just wrote in i
think i'm lonely
uh i remember you know looking back at
that now i think god i have all of these
like amazing friends and and people that
love to support me and that invite me to
go do stuff and i i have to say no and
how the [ __ ] could i have ever said that
i was lonely but i did
and i did feel that way for a long time
that's another thing i think that i try
and encourage people especially to do
with the black pill
mentality but also people that are black
pilled outside of the dating world
you just do not know what the future's
got in store for you and
bad periods in
my experience and in my observation just
do not continue for all that long
whatever it is that you're facing now as
the challenges are probably going to be
overcome pretty soon whether that's
loneliness or believing that you're not
worthy of happiness or acceptance or
friends or a friend group or whatever it
is
uh they seem to
they seem to find a way of fixing
themselves and the more that you have
belief you know the expectation effect
is a big part of this
do you believe that you're worth
something do you believe that you're
supposed to have friends do you believe
that you're worthy of happiness
this isn't the secret woo putting
yourself under the world stuff it's that
you will observe opportunities and take
advantage of them more effectively if
you believe that that's the way it is it
is a competitive advantage to have a
positive mindset
and as much as i still
can lay it to the feet of my uh
as you say
uh
anglicized heritage
the fact that we are sometimes dour and
a little bit uh
mopey
the difference is is a million
a million miles apart so yeah
congrats on 500k thank you any thoughts
on how the overturn of roe versus wade
could affect the dating market ooh
that is interesting
uh and part two would promoting higher
education to men in any form really help
when it comes to balancing the dating
pool more females at university etc
can't wait for the q a
good questions uh so overtone of row um
you're going to see
probably uh more choosy
higher standards from females for mate
choice reason being that the potential
externality of them having sex has now
been increased if abortion is less
freely available
women will have to raise their standards
because the price
that they pay for sex is potentially
higher and this is all subconscious of
course but i do think that you're going
to see um
less sex in a time when there isn't that
much sex at all
uh promoting higher education to men in
any form really help when it comes to
balancing the dating pool yes so the sex
ratio hypothesis suggests that whichever
the scarce sex is in a particular local
ecology are the ones that get to set the
rules if it's men then there are more
short-term mating opportunities more
casual sex if it's women then there are
more long-term mating opportunities more
relationships
longer waits as well between uh
meeting somebody and having sex with
them
i don't know how you get more men into
higher education at the moment um i
don't think that
it seems like a particularly welcoming
place for men to be i think that it
sounds like the sort of place that you
want to go with
rape allegations
and
um toxic masculinity and re-education
and
unconscious bias training and stuff like
that it doesn't surprise me that men
don't want to go into that especially
when from their side they can be a
laborer of some kind or a builder or
create their own business and do the
thing that university previously uh
permitted them which was money mostly i
suppose and to claim and status they can
achieve that in different ways through
computer games through
sports
and through starting a different
business here's another thing to
consider imagine
imagine if it's the fact that neither
men or women should be going to
university and that university is
basically a pointless qualification for
most people to have
but the difference is that because it's
so novel and new in terms of access to
women that they are yet to realize that
they've been cooked into believing that
it's something that's worthwhile
like it
very well could be the case that neither
men nor women should be going to
university but because men have had it
for so long they've seen the light
before women have and women are just
playing catch-up now if that's the case
it changes the
dynamic of how we look at
more women are in university that's
fantastic let's imagine for a second
just create a world where university is
a net negative for everybody that goes
don't think it is but imagine that you
could
then that flips the thing on its head
and goes oh my god we've got more women
going to university how could this be
the case i don't know maybe maybe that's
something to consider
kentucky brown kentucky brown kentucky
bound hey chris so glad to have another
opportunity to ask a question man love
that you're so interactive with your
followers it really means a lot and i
think i could save everyone here we
appreciate you
thank you very much it's very kind
question i heard you on the jre podcast
talk briefly about your mild dose of
autism [ __ ]
and you've mentioned it a bit before
here on modern wisdom my four-year-old
son was recently diagnosed with sensory
issues and they say his case is mild as
well i'm just curious what advice you
have for a father trying to raise a
child with these concerns any insight
would help thanks so much chris
so as i mentioned at the very start i
don't think that i have um anything
close to what would be diagnosed uh
especially at four years old uh
weird i was wheat i was a weird kid and
some would say a weird adult as well
but i am not the person that can give
you advice here that being said i will
um ask a couple of friends and if i find
any interesting information
i'll get ben to reach out to you uh and
i will see if i can send you some cool
stuff over
but yeah man this is outside of my wheel
of competence
no bot for you being a 21 year old male
and fascinated by your podcast i wonder
if at this stage in life do you think
having a healthy relationship is
preferred over having casual
relationships since in a long-term one
you have free mental space to pursue
passions or is it the other way right is
the other way around a better idea that
is a cool question so basically
do you want to be playing the field
so or not focusing on dating
so that you have more spare time or do
you want to have a relationship so that
it creates stability in the dating area
of your life
i i would
personally for me not try and
um
orient yourself too much i wouldn't try
and have too much of a predisposition uh
either way
you know you could come across the ideal
partner like the perfect girl for you
and you've created this
arbitrary rule where until the age of 25
you're not going to have a serious
relationship or you just let your dream
girl go
or conversely you could say well i want
to get into a relationship because
that's going to create a stable world
for me and you get into a relationship
with someone that you don't like or you
don't like enough and you waste your
time
i would just optimize for optimum
optionality and continue to tick over
with
whatever comes your way
the set point is always going to be if
it based on what you've written it
sounds like you've got
good control over yourself like you are
like a sovereign individual that wants
to go and be conscientious and
industrious and stuff you're going to be
fine whether you're in a relationship or
not the set point is always going to be
great for you because you're just going
to continue doing work you're going to
continue growing
the free mental space thing is great but
it gets lonely after a while and maybe
you do want a girlfriend for a while and
then maybe something happens and
you break it off i wouldn't have a
predetermined idea here i would go with
the flow but if you set yourself up for
success by having what are the
frameworks i rely on and stick to those
same thing goes for girls as well you
know like if you the most attractive
thing that a girl can do is to not need
a man
and then when you choose a man it's out
of choice not necessity that's the
difference right you want
to be you want to feel like your partner
wants you not like they need you
it's a huge difference
raj
pandya
hi chris congratulations on 500k well
deserved thanks for the lessons that
you've passed through your podcast it's
and it's guests easily my go-to podcast
thank you my question is you've
mentioned your own struggles in the past
with getting up out of bed in the
morning and the depressive state that
stops you from doing so what advice
would you have for somebody going
through this with a longing to be rid of
the negative cycle okay so i guess this
continues on from the slightly
morbid
lower uh vibration conversation i just
had before
i am a big fan of hubermann's
perspective at the moment which is that
you cannot change the mind with the mind
you have to change it with the body it's
not strictly true you can very much
change the mind with the mind that's
what meditation is but
getting the basics sorted is important
stop drinking alcohol for six months
have a stable sleep and wake pattern
every single day
make sure that you try and find
something or someone around you that
creates a support structure whether that
be a sports team a new sort of pursuit
crossfit training some friends whatever
it is eat and drink right it doesn't
have to be perfect you don't have to
lambast yourself because you had a
raspberry crumble from whole foods but
you do need to be eating enough protein
you need to be training and exercising
drinking enough water getting up and
seeing sunlight first thing in the
morning if you do those things you will
give yourself the best opportunity
in my
personal experience
i don't think based on the fact that i
don't have that same sense now
i don't think that i was
locked into some sort of depressive
state where it was out of my control i
have to presume given the fact that i've
changed my environment and that has
changed my mood and reduced basically
eliminated the depression
that it was external factors and the
external factors are things that i have
control over okay so
there is something in your
lifestyle which is causing this and it
may be a conglomeration of reasons right
that causing you to
feel depressed
what are they
for me here's an interesting one um
every week after freshers week which
would actually be two weeks time at
three weeks time from now
i would have a week in bed where i would
feel low energy i'd be ashamed of myself
i'd feel guilty i
all of the things i've said that you've
pulled out of previous episodes i
wouldn't get up i wouldn't
speak to anybody blah blah blah
and then the guilt and shame cycle would
continue from them which makes it worse
but that was because i'd worked so hard
during freshers week i just
invested way too much emotional energy
into the events and making sure they did
well and the
relapse after that was basically a
miniature burnout thing right
that was one of my triggers and i needed
to see that and i needed to have a
healthy relationship with
uh the way that i was working so i
dialed back the amount of emotional
investment that i put into things
um
making sure that you've got the
physical stuff sorted sleep wake
training sunlight someone around you
that you can talk to or people around
you that you can talk to limited
stresses non-sleep deep rests breath
work uh meditation all that sort of
stuff um sinking yourself into content
creators that you care about that care
about you that sound like they care
about you
whether that be through books or
podcasts or youtube or reddit or discord
or whatever right um
then what are the triggers what are the
things that are causing this to happen
there is going to be things that are
staring you in the face that you know
contribute to the beginning of that
negative cycle
and then again just know that
you will probably be out the other side
of this in five years time or two years
time or six months time
and
realizing that every day that you take a
step forward every day that you build a
tiny little bit more uh when rogan and
me were talking he talked about this
building a mountain with layers of paint
just laying down another layer of paint
today right to another good day
one final thing that i would say is i
used to i wrote this on that day one
journal as well such a sad read uh
i wrote once
that uh i was proud because i had a good
bad day
what i meant by that was i'd woken up
late which for me was my main trigger
for depression uh if i woke up late it
would make me feel like i was worthless
and i would feel guilty about myself and
i think well if i'm waking up at 10 a.m
what's the point in waking up at all i
might as well just stay in bed all day
and do nothing
um
that
was a trigger for me
but on the days when i did that and i
still
got up and
maybe my day wasn't perfect and maybe i
trained half-assed and
work was okay or whatever maybe it
wasn't but i had a good bad day um
overcoming the challenges that you have
is is super super satisfying so yeah
that's
some stuff there
uh pj tartak love the podcast thank you
for so many insightful conversations
thank you
question during an interview have you
ever had your mind wander off from the
conversation while the guest is speaking
in other words has your add kicked in
during an interview okay so i definitely
don't think i've got add uh i don't know
whether i don't think i've said that i
ever have um
that being said i mean
add is basically a spectrum of
how how well you're able to focus on
stuff and i think everybody has a form
of attention deficit at the moment
during an interview yeah it used to be
worse um and it happened
previously on episodes where i wasn't
super engaged with what the guest was
talking about
but
as i have
greater reach to choose guests that i
think are really really interesting and
also as i've refined down the ability to
hone in on the guests and to focus on
them
and i've drilled that routine of staying
in the present moment
that's pretty much gone away now uh
broadly which is good that being said
one of the times that it does come back
is if i feel a lot of pressure so
you may have had this before if
when you go up on stage to give a
presentation or there's something that's
happening that's like a big deal you
can't get out of your head and you're
sort of self-referentially talking to
yourself about the experience and you
just want to be in the experience either
because of pleasure or because it's
going to be more effective for your
performance
and you can't stop talking to yourself
about i can't believe i'm doing this
interview can you believe you're doing
this interview you're not thinking about
the interview why are you not thinking
about the interview yo look
just focus on the thing that's in front
of you that's what you're supposed to be
doing when pressure comes in that sort
of
metacognition kicks in a lot but
uh generally getting much better and uh
trying to not have my mind wander off is
a big deal also you can hide it quite
well it's pretty easy to hide if your
mind does go
um
yeah i can't i can't remember the last
time that it happened but i remember it
used to happen in the past and i was
just thinking where was i then come back
to it meditation's a big help for that
as well
look ladies and gentlemen uh that is an
hour and a half and a
[ __ ] ton of questions thank you to
everyone i love you all um i genuinely
do half a million is insane next q a
will be at 600 000
and lots of very very big guests coming
up soon the remainder of 2022 is going
to be wild please hit subscribe whether
you're listening on apple podcast
spotify uh watching on youtube it really
does help the channel
and for now
see you next time
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]